an attempt at making an identity thief
one of the most unlikable types of
people ever likable good luck
identity thief so identity thief stars
Jason Bateman he gets his identity
stolen by Melissa McCarthy now in a
whole roundabout kind of way he's gonna
go down to Florida where she is she's
living it up with all his money and
buying cars and a bunch of inanimate
objects that people don't need cuz
that's what women do with money and he's
gonna bring her back to where he lives
to serve up justice so it's another
roadtrip movie with two people who don't
want to be with each other
I think Melissa McCarthy was really good
in the movie Jason Bateman is really
good I mean Jason Bateman is really the
same character in everything which would
almost get annoying if he wasn't so damn
likeable in a role like that except for
dodgeball he was different in there I
think I speak for everyone when I say
I'd like to see more roles like that for
him get that hair Jason Bateman in the
new DBZ movie not really but he is
likeable so now he's being messed with
by Melissa McCarthy these were the good
in her role she kills it in bridesmaids
II know it's one of those things like
when Vinnie chase did Aquaman and
Entourage where she just had a hundred
scripts on her agents desks and
everyone's like hey we want you to be in
our comedy now please as enjoyable as
this movie is we have seen the two
people going on a roadtrip thing a
hundred times before this movie tries to
mix it up there's just one useless plot
point there's a hit man and a hit chick
or after them which would make sense
because she's an identity thief so I'm
sure she's pissed off a lot of people in
her life and you can argue that the road
trip does start because these two
attractive hit people tried to kill them
and they're running from him but the
road trip would have happened anyway
because Jason Bateman went down there to
get her it's almost like they forget all
about them and so do you then every half
an hour or so you see these people and
you're like oh yeah that's right there
these people are after them again still
still is the word and then they
disappear again and time goes on and
they forget about them and so do you and
then they pop up again this happens back
and forth until they just stop showing
up and you're like what was the point of
them I'll tell you what the point of
them is her name is Genesis Rodriguez
Genesis she is in the beginning God
created the heavens and the earth
heavens being this chick she's really
hot like she was also in Last Stand so
it's almost like people are like here
just put her in movies to play roles
that no one really cares about I mean in
last dance she played a role that didn't
matter either I mean you look at dude
eight planes trains and automobiles you
can have an enjoyable road trip
movie and not have someone chasing
someone so I was like this direction was
like nah we need that we need it because
we need to stand out so we're gonna
throw things in here that don't really
matter and look really forced and don't
fit worth [ __ ] and then they'll just
disappear
like it was never there although this
movie is a comedy this movie does have
deeper layers to it there are some
scenes with Melissa McCarthy and Jason
Bateman where they're bonding and you're
like alright I do empathize with a chick
who steals people's identities and ruins
their entire lives for a living in a
weird way that happened with this movie
identity thief is like this it's
enjoyable it's funny enough and serious
enough to kind of be in the middle it's
not a complete laughs out loud comedy
it's not a drama it's it's it's an
enjoyable enough movie it has enough
useless [ __ ] in the movie where it feels
Franny if the movie was about 20 minutes
shorter movie would be perfect but it's
two hours long because of the mobsters
that are in the movie that don't need to
be or low-level mobster hit people one
of which is a hot chick I will say
identity thief is a good time no alcohol
required Melissa McCarthy was good in
the movie Jason Bateman was good in the
movie they worked well together it's
just not good enough for me to say you
need to see it now alright so talking
about forest plot points in movies what
is the most forced plot point in a movie
that you've seen like I say to you force
plot point didn't need to be in the
movie what do you think of whatever it
is comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more